let's go next to our caller from the
four seven eight area code four seven
eight who's this where you're calling
from hey David this is Spencer actually
from Colorado Springs four seven eight
in Georgia one of the most conservative
places in the country dude let me tell
you my life story
I don't know how old you are but that
could be a very long story I'm okay okay
I'm 26 years old originally born in
Texas but grew up in Georgia obviously
very conservative area
oh you're talking about Colorado Springs
do I thought you said Colorado Springs
Colorado and then you went yeah okay so
then I moved from Georgia to Dallas
Texas and of course that's very
conservative although fairly I mean
there are a good number of younger kids
due to all the colleges down there right
and so I'm I'm finally like my college
fund runs out I want to run to somewhere
more liberal and or live with my views
and a little less humid tada Mackendrick
a didn't hate the Sun okay and I chose
Colorado and turns out Colorado Springs
yeah is the most I think it's in the top
10 most conservative cities in the US so
I made a very weird choice yeah and I
think that a lot of the I don't know if
it's like the the organizations that
sell disaster supplies like you know 80
pounds of mashed potatoes or whatever
but there's some industry that's really
big in Colorado Springs it might be
certain types of ministry I don't
remember now it's the evangelical
capital of the world got it there's
resort here every year yeah it's full of
right-wing money um to get to my
question I've been a huge foreign policy
wonk over my you know eight years or so
being really politically active and I
you know always bring up the military
budget
I think it's 706
eighteen billion dollars this last year
alright not mistaken but how would you
go about putting that in a way like
let's say Bernie Sanders gets elected
how would you go about cutting that in a
way to not stir up public fear because
the public overwhelmingly supports the
military obviously and I don't think the
vast majority of Americans can
understand like all the waste that goes
into the military so what do you think
would be the right strategy or the right
method of going about removing some of
that money from the military budget and
reallocating it towards social programs
or right well here's the thing so the
thing about the military budget is with
the military budget the debate is not
usually can we cut it it's can we slow
down the rate at which it's growing and
that's we need to even restructure that
debate before we can even really talk
about cutting it I think that there are
two basic ways that we could least
controversially start chipping away at
it one is there are all sorts of
programs that dictate the replacement of
all sorts of equipment on certain
schedules which are just handouts to the
military industrial complex let's start
to space those out like things that are
replaced every five years maybe get
replaced every eight like that alone is
going to start shrinking one piece of
that budget and then the other thing is
let's actually start shutting down
decommissioning certain bases around the
world I think the last time I checked
there we have like four dozen bases in
Germany or something like that I think
most Americans would be reasonably
satisfied that the US will be safe with
only 25 bases in Germany for example
that's an opportunity but we can
literally just start chopping things off
and yes there are people who work there
we have to figure out do they lose their
jobs or do they get moved elsewhere
these are things that have to be figured
out but if you want to cut the budget
that's going to come with the cutting of
some jobs and we have to accept that
yeah I feel the same way about how
people in the health care insurance
industry are gonna have to find new work
yep once they if it eventually comes to
that but one other thing relating to
that what do you feel about maybe
capping military spending yeah I mean
anytime you talk about that so sure I
have no personal opposition to it the
problem is those are the types of things
that one party will say we are
preemptively limiting ourselves without
knowing what the circumstances will be
so like I agree with you the we spend so
much already it's hard to imagine any
situation where a cap will actually be
in danger us but you will have someone
who says now we it's sort of like we
shouldn't ever take anything off the
table you're taking off the table the
possibility that in the future we might
need to do X Y or Z I don't agree with
that logic but some politician will make
the case and then it'll become an issue
of patriotism and then the left will
lose it yeah and like I said it earlier
that's my main concern with average
Americans their ability to you know
separate the facts of how much we spend
versus right like where we spend them
yeah but all right I appreciate you
taking my call oh thanks for calling in
yeah great to hear from you appreciate
it